lo que más demanda tiene es de tortuga y
el país más demandante son los asiáticos
todos los asiáticos este año siempre
cada año Tratamos de hacer es como un
reto de buscar nuevos mercados Nuevos
Horizontes nuevos clientes
[Música]
para cuando toca el día del empaque para
enviar una uva un fallo ya sea un falso
coral se alimenta tres o cuatro días
antes porque si lo alimentamos de un día
para otro el animal puede volver a
vomitar la comida que se le dio
lo que hacemos nosotros es que hagamos
una vez de la naturaleza solo una vez y
nosotros reproducimos el producto que
vamos a enviar entonces la explotación
de los animales no es posible porque
nosotros lo reproducimos en este en
estos locales que tenemos
por eso camino